World War three it's upon us this is
obviously tragic a lot of people are
gonna die this is so sad but it's great
for the memes World War three meme
review let's get it hopefully
it was realized if World War three
actually happens this video will not age
well
oh god but it's so good it's like
finally we have some dank memes again
finally it's what have we've been
missing for so long
me and my mates testing a friendly fire
is on after picked up uh it came back
the old name came back in it's great I
love it World War three caused a
worldwide nuclear apocalypse me who
saved bottle caps for years oh god I got
to stock up on bottle caps where my
bottle caps you know dying is bad and
all but at least it will make things
more interesting me a miner clicking I
am eighteen plus on prime hub army
trying to draft me for World War three
we see that you were over eighteen
interesting why is everyone running so
much I don't understand get the joke
haha guys calm down there's no way they
would have started work because one guy
died is it bad that I actually don't
know what that is well World War one
started why oh it was Franz Ferdinand
that's right Jesus Christ I can't wait
for that if someone dies in World War
three its PD PI's fault playing
pewdiepie playing berry pie nanana nanan
and then one like an Obama Ryan say no
more god dammit nice pretty pies fault
come on guys I imagined you at World War
3 with your homies and this [ __ ] pulls
up in the chat oh my god that's how you
know see the thing is like before people
just did stuff to be funny right now
people want to be funny so they can show
what else on social media you know
people are gonna pull off the weirdest
[ __ ] in the military you know it's it's
already happened basically where's that
image this meme encapsulates that just
perfectly World War two bombers
for Monica Veronica hey hey Monica hey
four day Monica it's not just good for
meme economy it's also good for mr. bees
content economy World War three starts
mr. bees last two survived World War
three where's 1 million dollars that's
so great giving it back World War three
starts Americans tries to flee to Mexico
gets blocked by a wall Trump in case we
haven't noticed you've fallen right into
my trap oh my he played us like a damn
fiddle US military you can't be drafted
if you're not mentally healthy me I'm
kind of [ __ ] I'm gonna be honest I'm
kind of [ __ ] you know I'm just
something of a woman myself I think what
makes me the most happiest about all
this is because this all happened in
January everyone's like oh no the year
started and it's already so bad for me
it's like well ad revenue so low in
January anyway it doesn't matter if this
video gets to monetize yay and I'm so
glad I didn't take a break right away in
January I knew I knew something good was
gonna come out of this World War 3 did
start in 2020 time traveler from 27 if I
reveal what me watching this video in
2018 me watching is not oh told Logan
Paul on his way to Iran after realizing
a world where Korea dead bodies what is
that actually real such a dead meme but
it still it pounds back just one more
time World War three will destroy the
peaceful lives of thousands we get a new
cod game afterwards everything has a
positive end there's nothing bad just
event when American gamers meet Iranian
gamers and realize it's their leaders
who suck and not them I mean yeah who
cares will you feel if you were American
would you feel any sense of pride going
into Iran being like yeah I mean there's
probably a lot of politics that I have
no idea how it works I'm Swedish
okay helped me I don't understand the
war but at the same time you know at
least they'll be fashionable doing so I
mean I can you can just green screen out
that outfit he's practically invisible
that's actually smart you may think it
draws more attention but neh when World
War 3 might start but the memes and the
subs are getting good again
small price to pay for dank memes that's
right that's what I'm saying
it's all worth it in the end guys come
on American soul your proudly yelling
you shoot me and your day in Iran where
being gay is a crime damn that's
actually smart so guys like don't be
scared just print it out on a t-shirt or
a flag is it really a crime to be gay in
Iran
well the meme said it so it must be true
I can't be bothered for tonight players
after they get drafted in one with real
what could that change skin mean Iran as
soon as America starts losing during
World War three I would like to get
there artist just disclaimer by the way
I don't condone any Wars I'm gonna go
ahead and make a statement here and a
hot take if you will
war war bad okay I will say it I'm not
afraid to stand the ground World War
three starts me and the boys
[Music]
you know suddenly I feeling my feminine
self suddenly it's just all make sense
iron soldier oh I thought you were dead
mobile gamer who watched an ad my death
was greatly exaggerating just watching
that guy really there's so much gaming
skill that's gonna translate into
warfare now that we really haven't taken
an account yet when you start World War
3 with us but only one plane shows up
only one plane shows up why is this not
the groom meme that's so annoying don't
come to Iran tomorrow Oh God Jesus
Christ don't want to mess with that last
thing Iranian soldiers see after Kylie
takes his strength
oh sorry after Kyle takes the strength
to put I thought it was like a Kylie
Jenner reference with the Pepsi guys
just drink Pepsi we can sort this out
with some Pepsi when someone get that
Pepsi these wars kid doesn't have to
happen just get their Pepsi Americans
when the tree starts became Vietnamese
Russians when the snow starts speaking
Finnish Iranian when the sky starts
speaking we are number one a babe that's
awesome I mean it's not awesome it's not
awesome
where is bad where is bad all right I
said it so I can joke it out when it's
World War three and you see the quiet
kid while on patrol we were guys we're
safe hands don't worry we got this we
got the special kid I mean special
forces your FBI agent watching you laugh
at means about World War three while
preparing your draft made way meth
addict alright what's your Excuse gonna
be for not getting drafted alright let
me hear it in the comments top one wins
an Xbox paid to win players showing up
to our end this is what I'm talking
about there's so much gaming knowledge
this Trump know about this cuz I think
he's shunned the games right he was like
they grew some video games if he only
knew the power of video gaming January
1st the fire pod pizza oven January 2nd
January 3rd what the hell was the fire
pod pizza oven there were simpler times
in last long World War three starts
constant players wait we don't get a
misis
Oh PC players what
just click well they clearly never
controlled an ac-130 above VR players
I've been looking forward to this guys
let me just do my minecraft redstone
engineering and I got this alright
the Iranian president chillin in his
crib oh so this is the live footage well
that's how it happened also this
Instagram comment with a lot of likes is
saying that USA killed the general of
Iran who was attempting to attack the
embassy so please check your facts I'm
not gonna check the facts I'm just gonna
take what this Instagram comment is
saying yeah World War three is totally
gonna happen because all of the big and
small meme pages who keep constantly
reposting the same unfunny screenshot
from Twitter every day Tom it was seems
legit yeah when I first saw the World
War three memes happening I'm like okay
this is just massively overblown
it's it's almost like people wanted to
happen just so they can meme about it
which I would never want that this just
bad war is bad war bad put it on the
screen we're not good we're not good I'm
gonna say it
we're not that big US Army you've been
drafted me I'm something of a Prag in
myself I am literally carrying the child
oh god I got to speed up there's so many
memes this this could be meme of the
year potential guys and it's already
January this is so amazing me showing up
in Iran after being drafted I don't like
saying I just realized it just hit me
randomly the government blind people
will not be drafted me yeah alright come
on don't ruin this don't ruin this my
World War three sergeant when we run out
of ammo because I was reloading after
every shot just to be sure what it
doesn't automatically refill all my I
remember when I was a kid and I play
battlefield and you can't do that
obviously you loose a bunch of ammo and
I think you might a fill and he's like
wow this game is so realistic I'll know
not to make that problem if I am ever
drafted in war shooting guerrilla World
War three
I knew they were connected but I didn't
want to be the one who said it so I'm
glad someone said it Iran declared war
UK declare Iran Germany declare
France everyone yo Germany hold up what
are you doing
Germany voice if World War 3 happens
historians will have to analyze our
memes as primary schools what was the
real cause of the outbreak well there
was a lot of memes there was an
overwhelming amount of memes wanting it
to happen
I like how I made a video criticizing
the media for wanting a shooting to
happening in correlation with the Joker
premier also PewDiePie World War 3 memes
u.s. Marine corpse want to play cod IRL
where you can rank up in real life what
when the guy with 900 plus hours in
World of Tanks gets drafted oh my god
when you find out priests don't get
drafted
what priests don't get drafted all that
would be so epic that's just that what a
disappointment I didn't know that 0.4
seconds after landing in Iran not like
the simulations this is not like the
simulator at Germany realizing they are
not guilty of this one I'm sure they'll
find a way when your special ed but the
government decides to deploy it to Iran
anyway all those funny gifts they've
already seen a million times
suddenly still much more epic Iran our
military is fully prepared for anything
America throws at us Japan we took out
like three boats and they unleashed the
Sun
twice yeah I asked about that in the
comments and everyone was like well it
saved more life Felix
American not bad okay we saved more life
by killing more cities stupid Felix
super hot players when they arrived in
Iran again another prime example of
gamers rising up when you found out
ninja is old enough to return you think
he'll be excused what a bad luck that
would be to be playing fortnight well
we're three about that but normal people
Oh God
read it that's hilarious I'm sure we'll
be really funny in the long run too
right when you're hardcore gamer but die
of four seconds after landing in Iran
yes for tonight kids when they land in
Iran they just started anyway I just
started building me and my brother after
faking autism so we won't get drafted
for the
military excellent now we can enjoy it
from a distance through reddit when does
battlefield 4 take place 2020 I ran it
ask it interesting when you call your
Minecraft girlfriend one last time on
the battlefield and the Iranian man's
phone in front of you starts ringing
when the US gets a new friend to play
knew you were my brother Trump asan well
that's all the World War three memes we
have for this episode of meme review
special episode very nice obviously
again were bad ok I've said it so you
can't be angry about anything I'm not
normally political in this channel but
war bad I'll rate this meme 3 because
World War 3 get it see you guys tomorrow
I'm never taking a break I tricked you
all
[Music]
you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the own poop
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need your hand
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prizes
[Music]
you